esta vez nos dicen se va a realizar una
prueba de significancia usando un nivel
de 5 centésimas supón que la hipótesis
nula es falsa si el nivel de
significancia se reduce a una centésima
cuál de las siguientes es verdadera
elige una respuesta pausa el vídeo y ves
puedes contestar lo bien vamos a
trabajarlo juntos están hablando de cómo
un error tipo 2 o la potencia cambian
así que antes de que revisemos las
opciones pensemos en lo siguiente hemos
hablado en vídeos anteriores de cómo el
incremento en el nivel de significancia
implica que la potencia incrementa así
que déjame notarlo y la potencia es la
probabilidad de no cometer un error tipo
2 así que estos dos disminuyen la
probabilidad de cometer un error tipo 2
ahora bien en esta pregunta vamos en el
otro sentido se está disminuyendo
el nivel de significancia lo cual va a
disminuir la probabilidad de cometer un
error tipo 1 por lo tanto también va a
disminuir nuestra potencia y esto quiere
decir que entonces la probabilidad de
cometer un error tipo 2 va a aumentar
así que cuál de las opciones
corresponden a lo que acabamos de decir
la opción am
plantea que tanto la probabilidad de un
error tipo 2 como la potencia de la
prueba disminuyen pero estos dos valores
no se relacionan directamente mientras
uno aumenta el otro disminuye y
viceversa así que vamos a eliminar esta
opción la opción b también plantea que
ambas cantidades se relacionan
directamente lo cual no puede ser
verdadero ya que mencionamos que si una
meta el otro disminuye así que voy a
cancelar también esta otra opción
el inciso c me dicen la probabilidad de
error tipo 2 aumentan y la potencia de
la prueba disminuye esto coincide con lo
que pusimos justo aquí la potencia de la
prueba va a disminuir si la probabilidad
tipo 2 aumenta fue justo lo que
establecimos acá arriba y por lo tanto
voy a decir que esta es mi opción
correcta el inciso cm y el inciso t es
propuesta eso dice que la probabilidad
de error tipo 2 disminuyen y la potencia
de la prueba aumenta está hablando de
este primer escenario que tenemos aquí
el cual va a ocurrir si se incrementa el
nivel de significancia no si se
disminuye así que también podemos
descartar esta opción muy bien con esto
en mente vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
anna tiene un centro de lavado de autos
y necesita decidir si comprar o no una
máquina expendedora para que los
clientes puedan comprar café mientras se
esperan adquirir a la máquina si se
convence de que más del 30 por ciento de
los clientes comprarán
ella planea tomar una muestra aleatoria
de n clientes para preguntarles si
estarían dispuestos o no a comprar el
café de la máquina posteriormente hará
una prueba de significancia usando al
pan igual a 5 centésimas para ver si la
proporción de quienes dijeron que sí es
significativamente mayor que 30% en cuál
de los siguientes casos obtendrán la
mayor potencia para su prueba ok de
nuevo pausa el vídeo y pepsi lo puedes
resolver por ti mismo bien antes de
revisar las opciones
pensemos cuáles son sus hipótesis su
hipótesis nula la cual podemos
considerar como el status quo es que no
hay cambios aquí esto es que la
proporción real de la población es del
30% 30% de las personas son las que
quieren comprar café ahora su hipótesis
alternativa va a hacer que la proporción
real de la población el valor real del
parámetro es mayor que el 30%
lo que nos interesa es cómo obtendrá la
mayor potencia para su prueba recuerda
la mayor potencia significan la menor
probabilidad de cometer un error tipo 2
y vemos como las opciones que se
plantean están relacionadas con el
tamaño de la muestra y el valor real de
la proporción poblacional de clientes
que compran café nota que el tamaño de
la muestra si está bajo su control no
así la proporción de la población es
imposible que se cambie el valor real
del parámetro lo que sí puede cambiar es
el tamaño de la muestra el principio
general lo que nos dice es que a mayor
tamaño de la población entonces la
potencia aumenta y por lo tanto la
probabilidad de tener un error tipo 2
disminuye así que queremos el mayor
tamaño posible para nuestra muestra y la
mayor potencia se lograrán con la mayor
diferencia posible entre la verdadera
proporción poblacional y la proporción
que se establecen en la hipótesis nula
así que queremos la n más grande de
todas estas y si observas esa n es 200
aquí tengo 200 y aquí tengo 200 también
queremos que la proporción real de
clientes que comprarán café esté lo más
alejada de nuestra hipótesis nula
de nueva cuenta esto no está bajo el
control de anna entonces vemos que el
50% está más alejado del 30% que lo que
está el 32% así que la opción correcta
va a ser el inciso de y hemos terminado
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo